[Music]
marketing for the now the marketing for
the now
marketing for the now marketing for the
now 10 minutes
12 remarkable guests for two hours
answering a singular important question
[Music]
are you ready gary what do you think
hi everybody welcome to vaynerx presents
marketing for the now
i'm andrea sullivan the cmo of vaynerx
and i'm here with
gary vaynerchuk happy anniversary
number 12 gary yes i guess our documents
say that this is the 12-year anniversary
invader
of my employment at vaynermedia i so i
got the email
i got it too i was laughing we opened up
a couple of
i guess we did because me and aj worked
on a project before
he graduated from school and i guess we
did it in april before he came
in late may and we started vayner so
thank you for that and thank you
everybody for tuning in
i know everybody uh uh is busy and has
lots of things going on so thank you for
joining us
we're super fired up for today's episode
we're going to be focusing on the future
of
music audio and sonic in 2021
and we're extra grateful for our friends
and our partners nick and jj
at the music business association
gary they actually reached out to us
they're big fans of marketing for the
now and they said why don't you do an
episode on of me
on music and we'll help you find some
guests and so that's just what they've
done
so uh super excited to kick things off
hashtag marketing for the now let's keep
the conversation going
and first up we have kara swisher
she is my idol she's the host of pivot
and sway podcasts
and contributing writer for the new york
times opinion
cara is an og in the audio space as the
host of recode decode podcast for over
five years
and an entrepreneur behind recode and
code
and revere digital she also co-produced
and co-hosted the wall street journal's
d
all things digital the major high-tech
conference featuring bill gates
steve jobs and many rock stars in tech
and media
and was a highly revered reporter at the
washington post
welcome pera how you doing how's it
going
hey kara how are you larry how's it
going it's really nice to see you it's
fun for me to be on the other side of
this
i get to ask the questions all right
good luck
i'm going to do my best here uh actually
let's let's make it very simple for me
um you know as you think about audio uh
we we set this up as what's the future
of music audio and sonic
and that can be sonic branding even in
2021
as i posed such a wide question
obviously you've just been
so incredibly strong in the last decade
around podcasting
but you know even as a consumer of music
or
and obviously your your consumer
behavior around digital is so
omnipresent
how do you take that question what are
the first things that pop up things
you're seeing things you're intrigued by
well you know it's really i find it
really nice they're very different
things like they're all different things
i'm not sure
i'm not quite sure what sonic is sonic
is sonic is like the intel
uh sound or the netflix sound there's a
there's a lot
of fun conversation around brands
and individuals even having a sound for
that quick one
second right as we continue to consume
content but i'll let you go
100 okay so i really do think a lot
about audio and you know as you know
i've sort of shifted my career rather
significantly about six years ago i was
a reporter i ran a big website
a big tech and media website was doing
really well and i really
you know i i grabbed an intern and went
and did reco decode it was me and a an
intern that did it by ourselves and i
was luckily working for a place
uh vox media that we're like okay we
trust you to do this and
the reason why is i've done so many live
events as you've done you know and
you've
also been a very big pioneer in this
area and i i saw the real um
resonance of this as the technology
started to really be available in the
way people consume these things
with a fan base that really it really
shifted from a written fan base to one
that
is in your ear in an audio format and so
that's not unusual because music has
been like that you have personal fan
relationships with the music you listen
to so it shouldn't be unusual that you
have the same thing with podcasts
and you saw some very early podcasters
like mark maron and a whole bunch of
them
that really did create and joe rogan
that created this really unusual
situation
and so i started i had been doing
interviews on stage
at the code conferences and all things d
before that and we had
no problem selling those out because
people like that in person live
experience
but i think more than anything they like
the talking experience
rather than being told things by
reporters they'd like to hear the whole
interview so that they can judge for
themselves it also gave people a lot of
agency
and so when i started doing them it was
i just decided
i could only do 16 a year of the big
names like steve jobs or bill gates but
then i could have hundreds of people
like hundreds of people that you don't
know of and people you need to know and
ideas that you didn't have and you could
really chew over ideas
so after i started doing them for recode
and we got to five or six hundred of
them at that at one point
um which is amazing which is an amazing
body of interviews um
the fan base it was crazy people would
come up to me on the street and felt
like they know you i'm sure this happens
to you
they i was in the target the other day
and was like we i love you i love this
it was like it never happened when i
wrote for the washington post the wall
street journal and stuff like that
and you really do give them a chance to
to be part of the conversation and then
the next iteration that's happening now
um besides doing you know i do pivot and
i do sway and
pivot's sort of a fun you know analysis
thing the others more substantive
interviews
is is these live events that i do both
on twitter and then twitter spaces i'm
not using clubhouse a lot of people are
using clubhouse i get it
is there any is there any reason you're
not cara uh i don't need to create my
enter
craft in another place like i want to
see what it can do
i don't i don't feel like starting
another thing i had a
i've been saying for a little while now
that i think clubhouse
absolutely has a place but i view it's
similar to snapchat where i thought
snapchat had a
place and then the stories feature
became a feature across platform
yeah you think that spaces on twitter is
going to be a feature we'll see facebook
and others yeah yeah it should 100 i
just don't see it as something that has
a lot of mode around it i get that
there's lots of people there and maybe
they can
like the way youtube did essentially uh
because there are a lot of people
do you think do you think you know i'll
take advantage of having you here
because you're such a great thinker
around these things
do you think it has a potential to have
that similar play as snap as
the original thing of the thing and then
and then
everybody has features or did snap have
the luxury of having so many more users
before anybody copied their feature and
clubhouse may just not have that luxury
you know i don't know i don't know
because people are creating their inter
graph there's they're doing their shows
and that's where they're locating it's
just like sub stack that's where they're
locating
it's just that they can move you know
what i mean like i can see like same
thing with sub stack all the others when
you think about these things and that's
not
audio or that's not music or things like
that but if you could move easily i feel
like that's a problem for any business
and and you could create when you have
better
better options and so i'm trying twitter
spaces only because i just don't feel
like
i like it it's a little glitchy but it's
getting there it's getting there i get
hun
you know you get thousands but i get
lots of people like i do them on friday
nights and i get like
up to a thousand people it's crazy it's
like awesome which is great and then
you like do you like hosting that party
yeah i do actually a lot because i
we have the live where i talk and i
answer written questions and that's kind
of
that's great too the live twitters and
they work out really well
but the the that i bring in guests and
people people want to hear from and then
people pop up in it it feels very
like that i i get the the um what's it
called there's
just the serendipity of it i really like
it and i like being at a conference
right like
you might be doing your thing there's
people listening a lot of people
listening and then as you're walking to
your next thing you might see somebody
you know and you're like hey why don't
you join
there is a little bit of that going on
no questions it's more like talk radio
that's what it really is that's what it
really it's less than a conference i
know they're describing as a conference
but i feel like it's because that's
still broadcast one to many even if it's
in a live space
this is like talk radio and i what i
found really interesting is two things
one
people calling in calling in right and
getting the chance and they want to talk
to the people and
the only difference the only difference
i'm sort of interrupt is
with the way you visually see it because
of the
who you are there are going to be many
people interested and you may be
interested in the person that's
interested so you can bring them in
whereas with talk radio that might be a
little bit more challenging
right that's you don't know who's
calling yeah so it's like even better
talk radio and yeah
and what's amazing is people have stayed
really civil i was sort of a little
worried about people popping off and
stuff like that and
there's a way to get rid of them quickly
i haven't had to do that all the
questions are intelligent people really
are dying for conversation
you know people are a little lonelier
now do you think that has to do with the
framework you've created as an
individual like that makes sense to me
if somebody said hey if somebody called
me and said hey are you paying attention
spaces it's really civil like that makes
sense because of the way
she rolls and what that audio yes it
works for me it doesn't work
it'll work somewhere like it doesn't
work for everybody the other thing is i
wonder
after the pandemic when people are
outside like whether they're going to
keep doing this that
that is a real obvious question and it's
not a fresh new one that i've come up
with
it's it's a fun question but what's
interesting is
but it will be more on there's an
argument for more of it to happen
as people micro on the go it might be
just a more entertaining
music or podcast absolutely or commuting
i think
what people don't understand is a lot of
people are consuming less audio
during pandemic because they're not on
the move
right a hundred percent i think we'll
see what happens with we've had a growth
we've had growth everyone's like oh
but i get nothing but growth for both my
podcast
what's really interesting to me is the
is the bigger trend which is about fans
and you have
pioneered this quite a bit but not just
this look at what taylor swift is doing
with redoing her albums it's all
i mean ben thompson wrote a great piece
about this it's all about
fans like whether it's cameo whether you
know i'm i just did an interview with
the cameo ceo
and everyone's like why i'm like are you
kidding this is a this is a direct line
to fans it's the same thing with nfts
the same thing
it's it's about people creating fan
bases and so the talent even substitute
the talent moves to the front and is
collecting the money and so
i think what's happening is what taylor
swift is doing
right now i don't think people are
appreciating quite honestly very
fascinating
because the middle the middle
is losing its leverage it has it doesn't
have leverage it's just showing that it
never did really it just got in the way
well it did because of the way
distribution worked and if you have an
upscale internet with an at-scale
blockchain oh my god yeah
exactly okay bad news these are only 10
minutes long good
all right thanks gary for doing this
have a good show all right
cool take care bye-bye bye next up we
have the incredible
ryan tedder ryan is a three-time grammy
award-winning songwriter
investor and entrepreneur he's worked
with
everyone from adele to paul mccartney
beyonce
taylor swift john legend and more in
addition to being
the lead singer writer and producer of
one republic
ryan is also a producer and mentor on
nbc's songland
which has just wrapped its second season
welcome ryan
hey thanks for having me right it's
great to see you
good to see you team throw up the
question uh after you
throw up ryan right we'll get right into
it because it's only 10 minutes i want
to get all your brilliant thinking
for everybody let's talk really fast so
we're good we're going to do damage here
i think ryan is in i wish in his intro
it said
is an entrepreneur and then went into
all the things we all know him for
because he really is
when you think about the future of music
audio and sonic
branding in 2021 let's use music since
we have the luxury of having you give us
an
insight because you are so ear to the
ground of trends consumer
what's catching you off guard what do
you think people aren't talking about
with where music's going in 2021 um
i mean obviously we stumbled into in the
last conversation into the nft thing
right non-fungible token
um that uh personal one-to-one
interaction
with your fan base is absolutely the
most vital
you guys i loved where the conversation
went just a second ago into taylor swift
of it all
i've worked with taylor on a number of
records and she's a savage and she's
going to reclaim her own fan base and
she will remove the middle man which is
the label
um i knew that was going to happen the
moment she called me and told me she was
going to do it i was like
you're going to do it um look uh albums
are malleable now i have this
conversation incessantly i'm executive
producing
seven albums at the same time right now
i just did the single with john legend
for space jam 2.
like i'm i'm doing a ton of other things
in music
nobody can pull the levers anymore the
way they used to
pull it with songs so i'm working with
little nods x
on upcoming stuff i can't again i'm
ndate out the butt i can't talk about
i knew i i signed the writer that wrote
peaches for justin bieber i signed him
three weeks before he just came out
we got lucky and like it went number one
right i knew that he had some hits
coming i didn't know he's going to go
number one
peaches by all intents and purposes
should still be number one except a
little thing called little nazax
who is the biggest marketing genius in
the history of the music industry
by far i've been betting out that guy
from day one the moment i saw the video
the moment i knew that he was doing the
nike
dropping the shoes release like the you
know the satanic
shoes that he then got sued by nike all
of it was so brilliant
but it highlights one very very
important thing music industry has
shifted to a degree where
the song itself is not the driver
right historically if you had a great
song now it's not to say great music
can't rise and cream won't come to the
top there will always be those anomaly
unicorn songs that pop off regardless of
marketing
it's going to happen but um you know
you've got ollie oberman coming up here
soon who's a friend of mine
bite dance tik tok um you know if you
don't have something that's
active right now and tick tock tick tock
is the new mtv it's
mtv it's radio it's it's
uh posters on telephone poles it's all
of it wrapped into one
and if you either don't have a fan base
that is nuclear hot the marketing
prowess of a little nausea
or a song going off on tick tock you're
in trouble
trouble i don't care how good the song
is by the way dick clark
the local disc jockeys and big markets
uh mtv we just talked about the source
rolling stones magazine there's always
been curation
the differences the platforms that
curate now
are empty vessels and it's the artists
and the teams around them yeah their
strategy not
i'm not the no longer i run mtv and you
and i are best friends and i'm going to
put you on 800 times
can i give you can i give you a 30
second anecdote all right so i just
worked with portugal the man who did you
know
i'm a rebel just for kicks man
right right that there are there isn't
they're an indie band from portland and
alaska who had never had a hit in their
life
and then phillip still goes off and
smashes the second i heard that
song the second i heard i heard it two
days after it came out
i i played it in the background at a
pool party i was like this is a this is
smash
like this is a no-brainer i asked them
last week i said who at the label
flagged at as a hit
they said everyone in our label didn't
like it and it was like
relegated to track five or six or
whatever on the album nobody thought it
was it
okay first the intermediaries don't know
right and i'm not crapping on labels
across the board because there's some
phenomenal a
rs but the best a r in the business at
least at some point
had the ability to pull levers the
internet
the world culture has taken over music
conan gray who's by the way ryan i
apologize for because you're wrong
the world always did there's been
yes a ton of smash hits from 1987 yes
that the world decided
not everybody thought the difference is
your point the label used to cut songs
out
now there's almost no reason to correct
there's no reason to there's no reason
to do it
no there's no reason to and i hate
saying more is more but more is more i
mean
conan gray is a prime example he's on
republic records superstar kid
artist dropped an album a year ago
called kid crow
did did okay did fairly well uh the song
that he begged the label to put on
called heather it's the only song you
wrote by himself just him on an acoustic
guitar
seven months after the album comes out
somebody grabs it does something on tick
tock
boom biggest smash he's ever had in his
life counting stars which we put out six
years ago
went viral two months ago the head of my
leg or the head of international calls
me
what are you guys doing with counting
stars we're getting we're getting 1.2
million streams a day on it
turns out some dude in like austria sped
it up put it on tick tock people danced
to it
it went off the point is nobody nobody
knows
everyone who thought they knew knows
even less nobody
nobody can control what a hit is
anything real quick real quick yeah you
also said lil nas x
is the greatest marketer in music
history period so you said
nobody can control i counter because i
know you're just in
the artist if they're the marketer if
they're the marketer period if you're
not pulling the strings
authenticity smells much
has such a more pleasant smell than
perfume and anything else you try to
perfume a package with
authenticity will cut through right so
when you're doing it authentic
this i apologize this this show started
with me my 12-year anniversary at least
on a legal document of starting vayner
at vaynermedia
12 years ago the thesis was oh my god
technology is going to kill
everything in the middle completely and
the only thing in the world that's going
to matter
besides the skill itself because even if
you're good at hacking the thing has to
still be good is the ability to
communicate in the modern moment
and so i decided to eat [ __ ] for 12
years and build an agency to have a
machine
behind me and that's basically been the
entire conversation so far between
karen now you yeah i mean that's 100
what it is man and i'll and i'll cut to
the nft of it all and i'll cut to also
blockchain music which i think is you
got two minutes so i'm giving you
everything
go so so look i'm i'm e-peeing seven
albums which is
the most i've ever done in my life which
is i don't even know seven times you
know
10 let's say 70 to 100 songs these are
some of the best albums of these artists
careers
according to them their label their
parents their wives but i have no
control over which songs will go or
which won't i've i've removed the stress
factor from that the world will decide
so
if the democratized music has changed we
used to be able to
gas a song from a number ten to a number
three we can't do that anymore right you
can't do it
let's pivot into modern music
non-fungible tokens nfts
um it's fascinating i'm doing my own
drop with origin protocol i think
they're
for me personally the best in the space
right now um
it is such a unique way of interacting
with your fans in creating
art for art's sake and scarcity make
something valuable
if you give [ __ ] and you actually care
about it in your and i said this
nfts is an ocean don't get on and try
and hop away
if you don't even have a surfboard and
you never know how to surf and a lot of
people are
are getting on and trying to surf the
wave and they're they're falling apart
like this is an ocean build a boat and
then make it bigger
and make something people want to float
on in the nft space that's my analogy
for nfts in terms of art music
now as where it could go potentially in
more disruption beyond spotify and
everything else
and i don't i'm poking at the space now
just to see but the idea of
there's a company called rocky it hasn't
done a whole lot yet but
their whole thing is music on blockchain
like putting songs
on chain a streaming service on the
blockchain
where you're getting paid directly
you're getting paid directly from the
consumer and the consumer also
is getting paid in incremental little
bits of blocks or you could call them
satoshi's
right they're getting paid to listen so
there's an interest
where this goes i don't know but i've
been betting on the blockchain for
four or five years you know like so i
i'm a believer that
that somehow decentralization is coming
in every single category transparency
authenticity decentralization that's the
theme for the next 10 years
see you my friend love you peace
next up we have john coyne vp and gm of
brand
creative and media at intel john is
responsible for brand product identity
global creative and social
john's team just launched the biggest
rebrand in intel history
which includes a re-imagination of the
famous
intel sonic bomb
the og sonic of all sonics oh and most
importantly gary
john is a die-hard pittsburgh steelers
fan welcome john
great to be here
i didn't like that steelers part john i
was just playing around who's wondering
if you're
if you're with me or again i'm very
against you i'm a jets fan you beat me
in two
very big playoff games in the last uh 15
years that broke my heart i went to
pittsburgh for both some great people
but devastating outcomes for me
including one that was
the ticket to the super bowl which i've
not been to you've been to many i find
you greedy
uh and not letting us win that game but
john i'm really happy to have you here
because as the question is about to pop
up
um you know the future of music audio
and sonic
is the theme here today you know
i to me the intel sonic branding
is the mount rushmore you know
and that dude dude like that that to me
is
such a big deal and i believe
that the entrepreneurs small businesses
and big businesses that are listening
here
should be creating a sonic brand and
should be using it every piece of their
content
every one of my videos on instagram
start with gary garyvee it is like to me
incredibly important
spit some wisdom and and share what
you're allowed to with us
around sonic branding where you see
sonic branding and then in the way that
andrea
set it up it sounds like you'll be able
to get into a little detail yeah happy
too
so um i came to intel about four years
ago one of the reasons i came
was because of the incredible brand uh
it's one of the most
valuable brands in the world and it is
because of the
you know kind of the iconic brand
elements that intel has including
the intel bone it really is the the kind
of the original
sonic audio uh branding device and
it's one of the most valuable assets
that intel has as a company and
we as we just talked about we're going
through a pretty
dramatic brand transformation that we
launched last fall
uh aligned to where our business is
going and as part of that we wanted to
re reimagine how people experience intel
and make sure that we aren't just a
company from 50 years ago when the
company started but we are
a company and a brand pointed towards
towards the future where intel's going
and so we looked at the intel bong and
saw it as an opportunity
to read just to reimagine it a little
bit so what we did
is as part of the brand launch we
updated the intel bong it's not been
changed much
over the years it's the same five notes
it's the same
kind of melody that everybody knows and
loves so you that hits your ears in that
way but it also will
hit your ears a little bit differently
so you hear it's a little bit fresh
a little modern maybe a little bit
contemporary and we've got kind of a low
intensity bong a high intensity bong
we've got
custom bongs that we're making that fit
on the content
in a certain way because one of the
challenges that we had is our
our bong often lives on our partner
content
and it would kind of just land on the
end of it you know kind of
abruptly and not necessarily integrate
really well so one of the things we
wanted to do was to be able to
create versions that live kind of more
uh
organically with the content that it
exists with so
that's what we've been doing but i have
to tell you the key uh
to the bong and i would say to somebody
who's trying to think about how do they
create
a sonic uh audio mark for their company
i think the key is consistency of course
we as marketers
uh love to change it up but you've been
interested
john you pounded this sound in my mind
by the way real quick derek hunter i see
you in the comments
the way i process information is by
biting my nails i know that it is not
a great enjoyment from people that care
about grooming
but for me it has worked for 40 years i
will continue to bite my nails
uh because it helps me process and think
and john is dropping some wisdom
john i think that's exactly right i
think you know that matters
and by the way i find that a lot of jet
fans have that same problem oh god
listen john you got 10 minutes here i'm
more than happy to make it five don't
get me crazy
honestly is like the benefit of intel
why does everybody know
intel bong and love it it's because
billions of dollars literally over 27
years
has been spent drilling it into people's
heads
and and i think you know one of the
things that we have to fight is just the
desire
to change and lose interest and want to
do something new
so one of the best things that any you
know company can do is think about how
what is that consistent
thing that i can deliver over and over
and over a period of years
because it takes people a long time to
actually be able to
internalize into here and to remember uh
that that sonic device or
you know that tagline or you know that
voice
uh you know that font that you're using
we've got to really uh
understand that for people to start
internalizing it
it takes time and repetition so be
patient
stick with it don't lose interest in two
years uh
and you will find that that truly will
pay off john
the segway in our four minutes you the
human
not the executive okay where are you
with podcasts do you listen to them
don't you and based on what i like to
iterate along the way based on what kara
and i were talking about
have you found yourself consuming more
or less of it
in covid versus where you were
pre-covered uh
i'm absolutely obsessed with podcasts
and i know
i'm obsessed with uh cara as well and i
listen to her podcast so
i love that honor to be on here with her
uh i found that in the especially in the
pandemic you know when i've got kind of
more time
uh i'm listening to more podcasts i'm
getting more variety i'm getting more
voices
uh give some i think i think i think
giving shout outs and cosigns is good
karma
give us three to four to five or one or
two or three uh give you another second
to think
of what you're actually listening to uh
podcasts that you really enjoy and why
yeah well uh i'm definitely uh
i like uh uh cara and scott uh so um
yeah with that uh you know both of their
podcasts i love the daily
uh i listened to anything on npr uh you
know
just a variety of podcasts there and and
it's just uh
and i'll just listen to industry ones
things on marketing different things
and that's also the fascinating things
with uh that's going on with
clubhouse and other things like that too
is i'm just are you are you spending
some time in clubhouse
yeah i'm just experimenting you see and
do you do you like
audio because you're able to do
something else as well whether it's
walking the dog working out
in the background cooking drinking like
do you like that
you hit it i i listen to podcasts and
audio and i'm riding my bike which
try to do as much as i can uh when i'm
working out when i'm walking the dog
those are the big three
i'm always doing something else it's
very rare that i'm just sitting down
doing one thing i'm always doing two or
three things
and listening to audio podcasts uh
it's just a great way to engage myself
kind of in that other dimension
and just even this morning i had a few
minutes jumped into a clubhouse
you know conversation about marketing
versus sales it's like okay that's just
great while i'm doing something else
i get to stimulate you know my thinking
and i just am obsessed
with podcasts and i think you find
yourself are you a better learner from
audio than you are visual
or written word or which one of those
three tend to
like sink in the most yeah it's
interesting i've found as i've gotten
older uh i've my eyes aren't as good
audio is totally
my best way to learn uh honestly it's
just because it get
it gets in my head and i'm able to kind
of process thoughts
almost without working at it that hard
uh it just kind of gets in there
john uh final thoughts a lot of
entrepreneurs in the chat as well
how should small you know i own one
pizza shop
i'm a influencer you know they they see
you that iconic thing billions of
dollars spent to get there
what's just a practical thing for them
to think about with sonic branding
do you think they should go the route of
making one and if so
how do they how should they think about
deploying it yeah i
i mean i think you've got to think about
your community you know that
sir you don't have to be intel where
you're you know for the world
yeah exactly but you're you know your
pizza shop in your neighborhood
you know in your community uh obviously
there's lots of great really targeted
digital ways of reaching you know
customers in your area and i think just
think about uh you know every time
you're kind of delivering that
that message if you do develop that
unique
just signature you know that that starts
getting that mnemonic
in your in your customers heads about oh
god that's
tony's pizzeria you know whatever that
audio mnemonic is
just be consistent you don't have to be
big you don't have to be global yep
you've got to be relevant
you've got to know where you're where
your customers are how to reach them
uh and be consistent yeah just try it
just
just go for it and see what happens john
thank you it's such a pleasure a
pleasure thanks for having me here
appreciate it
our next guest carrie champion is a
broadcast journalist
tv personality and podcast host of the
brown print
carrie is an expert host for multiple
hit shows including
vice tvs carrie and jamelle stick to
sports
amazon's nfl next live tnt's the arena
nbc's reality competition series the
titan games
which was created and presented by
dwayne the rock johnson
kerry continues to break barriers and
pave the way for younger women of color
who want to pursue a career in
broadcasting which is why she founded
brown girl's dream
welcome carrie
there sounds like carrie are you okay
there seems to be like a robot going on
that is i think an alien robot has taken
over your audio
we can't hear you carrie
[Music]
while kerry's trying to figure that out
uh okay
teams put me on team uh andrea i'm fine
with if the next guest here and maybe
the team can work with carrie if not i'm
happy to hold down court for a little
bit
sounds good do we have curtis in the
house
yay
why don't you do the intro andrea and
we're curious to get her audience
costell curatus is amazon music's global
head of artist marketing and works
directly with artists across a wide
range of genres
since joining amazon music earlier this
year curtis has led marketing efforts
for key initiatives including
breakthrough amazon music's new
developing artist program
amazon music's friday live series which
has raised money for covet 19
relief efforts through live performances
from duolippa
katy perry and tim mcgraw curtis also
worked
extensively to lead amazon music's
efforts to support communities affected
by covid19 crisis
with with artists including megan d the
stallion
with throughout the pandemic welcome
curtis
hi hi curtis how are you i'm good gary
how are you
it's really nice to have you here thank
you
so you know how is it navigating
these you have amazon's such an iconic
global company
uh the music initiatives have uh been
really really
revving up uh and so kudos to you and
your team
how are you thinking about you know
music
strategies music consumption music
trends in the 2021 world when i
when i painted that way very very
broadly where does your mind go to right
away
well there are a couple of things i
think first of all
uh working at a music streaming company
music streamers
have to evolve right and become
more than just a music store
artists and their fans are looking for
you know other opportunities
and and they want more than just a big
catalog of music um so we're working to
make amazon
amazon music a home for creators right
like if you want to
if you want to create a podcast if you
want to i mean an artist like they put
all their heart and soul into this music
and they want you to hear it the way
they created it right so we've got high
you know we've got high def
audio if you want to hear your music if
you want your fans to hear your music
in high definition we you know
we supply that like there's if you want
to stream directly to your fans like
we've got live streaming um with our our
partnership with twitch
that goes directly into our app like
you've got to be
more than just a play button now for for
artists and for their fans
i think that's exactly right what um
what has been the most
interesting thing that you've observed
with consumer behavior in the last
12 months from your perspective from
your seat
looking at this has there been anything
that is like wow
if gary said this was going to happen or
if i said this was going to happen a
year ago i would have never believed it
or just a big shift in behavior anything
anything stand out when i say that i
think
because of the pandemic like from an
artist standpoint
i'm seeing more artists focus on their
broader brand than just on the music
right like the music
is going to be the fuel that powers
everything else
but you know you've always had a couple
of a-list superstar
artists that had a fashion brand or you
know or
headphones um but what i'm seeing is
that
younger artists are paying more
attention to their broader brand
um i mean i think i've heard you know
that doesn't align with our
our brand more in the last couple of
years than i
ever have and i think specifically
because of the pandemic
we're going to hear that more and more
if if you were an
artist that was relying solely on your
music
and the ability to tour or to perform
live as your means of income to support
your
career i think that
they've learned a good hard lesson in
the last year
and everybody's gonna be focusing more
on on their
broader brand um i think from a
marketing standpoint
it probably hasn't changed as much as
you would think right
it's still our job to get your music
and your brand as far and as wide as
possible
to give people and fans and potential
fans the opportunity to vote
right like yes so i from from that
standpoint i don't think it's changed
that much
great content um social media
has made that a lot easier i think you
know what ryan was saying earlier about
tick tock
it the destination for artists
that you know and i mean are you kidding
me you look at the top
of the of the hits the numbers the ma
you know what's so great now is it's
math this is not
oh we're gonna give the grammy to this
person this is math who the world's
listening to
and you can map what's going on tick
tock with the top of the charts
in the easiest most binary don't even
debate with me this is a foregone
conclusion
just because the sheer amount of
attention i had three
i actually made a video today that will
probably come out tomorrow my instagram
or what have you
i had three eight-year-olds come up to
me just now and say
gary b we love your stuff i'm like how
old were you guys you're like
i'm like that [ __ ] tick tock boy you
know like
absolutely it's like i mean i hear more
about tick-tock strategy to touch what's
our tick-tock strategy which are you
know
and it's it's like ryan was saying you
just don't know anymore right you could
have best laid plans you can make you
can create the best marketing plan
and somebody gets on a skateboard on
tick tock
and you know drink some cranberry that
is that is
out of here that's ocean sprays most
successful commercial in the last 40
years
ever and they listen for free
ever what advantages
you know when i think about amazon i'm
like man they are so
integrated vertically yeah you know when
i think about the streaming things what
why artists may want to lean into amazon
i'm just this i'm just getting a little
business nerdy i apologize to everybody
because i'm being selfish right now
i i think that there is some really cool
advantages
that amazon has over other places
because of their ecosystem right
have you know and i see you with that
smile now so maybe there's some things
you can't speak to
oh good so like happy to talk about are
we in the place where eventually
like the biggest artist in the world may
want to exclusively drop with you guys
because
she may get her picture on all the boxes
that get delivered that week like
it feels like you've got prime you've
got you know
so many kind of things uh to your point
as these
artists become more brand oriented if
they want their book to be successful
they may want like it feels as though
from afar that there are some real
opportunities for integration is there
anything of that going on yet any plans
i'm just uh so i'll tell you
one of the so i'm the head of
artist marketing and one of the channels
that i manage is something called
cross category which means we are the
primary entry point
into all of the other amazon business
units for
for music artists it's one of the
reasons i i came here it's one of the
reasons i left you know the recorded
music world and came to the dsp side
because
my passion is breaking artists right and
amazon has the tools to break artists
and to you know and for superstar
artists
who you would think you know they have
all the fans in the world
we can help them expand that fan base
even more and
i'll give you an example a couple of
examples we
worked with carrie underwood over the
holidays she gave us an amazon yes
yes i remember yep she gave us an amazon
original
um for for holiday music and we ended up
using working with the ring team um to
position that song in their holiday ad
campaign
and carrie was part of that campaign
right like so
something that was supposed to just be
you know a holiday original song
for amazon music we were able to
partner her with ring and make that
and that's more and that's more you know
that's more
distribution and awareness for her and
yeah and it makes a lot of sense
right like it would work for the ring
team um
i'm so i'm so devastated we've run out
of time i just want to say this real
quick
we haven't had a chance to jam in person
but the
the amount of nice accolades you get
from people that we know in common
for who you are as a person is what
something i wanted to say to you in
public
not only private keep doing your thing i
can't wait to get to know you better
thank you yes i'd love to
next up we've got wendy ong president of
tap music
wendy oversees an incredible roster of
rockstar artists
including dua lipa ellie goulding lana
del rey
noah cyrus dermot kennedy haley
steinfeld and more
joined the tap music team wendy worked
as head of marketing at roc nation
where she drove campaigns for jay-z
rihanna
jaden smith and more welcome wendy
thank you andrea and hi gary i'm very
excited to be on your show
thank you wendy that was a incredible
intro
and it's such a pleasure to have you and
your background is so beautiful the
flowers make me feel happy it's raining
in new york
that was the whole point you know bring
on bring spring into your show
thank you wendy right to the question
because we're running out of time
because we have such a great lineup what
is the future of music
audio and sonic in 2021 very broad
question you could take it anywhere
you've been probably listening a little
bit in the green room what what
what can you add context to what do you
what what did it make you think what
should people hear based on what they've
already heard so i
really took on board everything that uh
ryan had to say as well as curious who's
a really good friend of mine
and what i wanted to add was especially
for
major artists who already have a
devoted and loyal fan base like i'm more
interested
you know and no disrespect to the
amazons and spotifys of this world like
i'm more interested
in fostering that relationship
the direct relationship between the
artists fans because they're the only
two entities that that matter to me
as they should exactly i i don't know
that that is actually true of
many other companies you know i'm not
talking about management but
music companies in general i i think
that
could be a little misleading where their
uh
heart lies i guess so you know my
my take on your question is um
i'd like to explore building independent
artists economies that are uh
that are functional economies enabled by
blockchain you know and i know that
sounds like a bunch of words
that are thrown together but essentially
like i
i look at like the bigger artist with
their devoted fan base like
why shouldn't we have something where
you know if we were gonna
if we were already at this level and we
wanted to drop
you know anything from an album to
special merch and all that
and why can't we do it on our own you
you will wendy i don't want to scare my
great partnership at harpercollins
but i'm going to be transparent right
now because i want to bring value i
am wrapping up my book contract i have a
big-time book coming out this
winter that i'm excited about i
was in the process of signing another
deal
i'm not sure i will there's something
called
blockchain and nfts right there's a lot
of i've been
i'm not a dummy i've done a lot of
homework and i know exactly where this
is going
and the answer is why wouldn't i the
answer is
of course it's exactly what i should do
and so what's going to happen is
the people in the middle are going to
have to evolve
that is the name of the jungle right
wendy
absolutely and i think that's where
blockchain comes in and you know
everyone that you talk to like
nfp nfv nfp that is like the big
buzzword right not the moment right now
it is but you know i think that that i
personally have concerns that still need
to be addressed in this whole world and
i'm speaking as a layman like i'm not a
texan
you mean no i i'm worried with how
white male centric every person that
talks about this is that that is a
concern to me
i think it needs to have you know what's
good you know what's good about that
it's one thing about white tech nerds
talking about it it's another thing to
know that it's a decentralized
economy that actually the thing you're
worried about with your opening sentence
then you should be most optimistic about
this platform because it's the first one
that's come along
that most addresses your opening concern
right
absolutely that's because that's who's
first talking about it that's just tech
nerds that's the math of what
happened that is society no different
than if it was athletes talk about
athletes
the demo would look different like
that's just the nature but the
actual macro nature of decentralized
servers
actually addresses your anxiety
yes but that in itself like opens up
another can of worms you know like the
environmental impact and i know that's a
very convenient
no it's not it's not a controver it's
not controversial
it's a good it's a good conversation
yeah right but you get companies saying
like oh
don't worry about that we're going to
offset our carbon footprint but
are you really doing it what what
measures are you going to take that i
went next
wendy you know what else takes an
ungodly amount of servers
amazon right netflix this is
this is new your first like you know
like i laugh with people of course it
has server impacts
do you know what it takes to keep up
amazon music servers that we just had or
netflix
or spotify it takes servers and to your
point
this is early and they keep evolving you
know what else happens wendy do you know
what
the environmental impact is on producing
a cd or shipping it or that like there's
always
offsets we don't know we don't know yet
where it lands to your point
right but then you know with with my
artists
and their fans you know like i have to
be interested in the issues that make
them take
and and but also but real quick
i apologize but if they're going to be
fair
you know let's talk about what the
apparel industry
and what that does to the environment
and i'd like to know the collective
amount of money that the t-shirts and
the wristbands to coachella like
like you know you know what we've come
into is a world where people are picking
and choosing right what they're pointing
fingers at
and you have to look at that hypocrisy
because the textile industry
the clothes do we really need a hoodie
with julie bonnet
well you know well you know
and i think and wendy it's important
because i know we're having a thoughtful
conversation these are going to be the
thoughtful conversations that happen
right because i think what happens when
something new happens
is and you're bringing up the right
question you have to debate it i love
i couldn't agree with you more are your
artists while i got three minutes i'm
enjoying the [ __ ] of this
are your artists bombarding you with
like wendy what the [ __ ] are we doing
with nfts has that been like the last
two months
of course they are you know and actually
i don't know enough about this company
yet but then i
i am going to call them out because i
think that what they're trying to do
is interesting and it's a company called
rally and i've only had one conversation
with them and i'm
looking forward to having more but you
know it very much
like they are trying to address
increasing that fan engagement you know
building that independent artist
ecosystem like what you were talking
about earlier with curators
um and and also reflecting the diversity
the diversity of all that we're doing
needs to reflect
the creator community the makeup of the
creator community
so i think yes every one of my artists
is asking about that but they
are asking with the issues that i've
just
you know you and i were just debating as
well another interesting aspect to
what nfts are leading to it's not just
about the
you know whatever the piece of artwork
or video that you throw up but you know
it leads to the experience
experiential element of this as well
right
where it's a digital fan club with vip
access and all that
i don't know how that's all gonna play
out i think it's it's still the wild
wild west and we're still watching and
learning
but live streaming for example right i
think that uh
and you know cryptocurrency could have a
big role to play in
in live streaming especially now that
you know that when you're we're seeing
the light at the end of the
tunnel at some point probably more like
next year there will be touring
right there will be concerts again does
that mean we completely disregard how
we've learned to work this past
year um i don't think so you know i
think that there is room for a hybrid
model like we had a very successful
live stream show with dua you know with
her show it's twenty-two
four and the reason that was successful
was because
it wasn't just somebody sitting at home
and watching an
artist on stage like it was crafted like
an incredible tv special
you couldn't take your eyes off it like
there was something happening at every
second of the show
um and i think there is probably room
for a hybrid model of that
and for fans to be able to engage more
with that kind of show
that they are missing out on if they
were watching it in person
oh i mean people are i'm gonna like
run out naked and kiss everybody's face
the second they let me we are
every i mean and to your point this
smart contract
is what you're referring to under an nft
that is going to allow for green room
access pre-show different seating events
like
there's so much coming to your world and
i've just been such an admirer from afar
of your career wendy and i'm so glad
this was the opportunity to jam and i
hope we crossed paths again and
i uh i wish you well thank you gary take
care
take care
andrea you're on mute
thank you gary you're welcome i hope
that the robot has released
carrie champion and that she can come
and join us right now
hey it's normal guys it's normal
thank you guys for helping me of course
carrie it's so great to see you i'm glad
the alien robots have
released you and uh and it's great to
see you and and what an incredible intro
you you know
as many know i'm a fan and believer in
work ethic i think it is one of the
ingredients
and you know i just admire yours from
afar
you are a renaissance woman doing tons
and pushing and i cheer for you oh man
thanks i appreciate that you're very
kind
i i far more far more of a fan of yours
than
than than mine i'm sure but you have to
understand when you
sit around the house and we all talk
about me and my girlfriends because
streams of income how to how to make
sure you're not worried
um i come from a family where we live
check to check and i just i just knew
growing up i would never
want that for me you know what i mean
and my family and i wanted to make sure
i was being smart
and learning how to invest because
sometimes the keys are not given to us
and we have to find them on our own
that's facts
carrie when we talk about the future
music audio
which you play in um and sonic branding
which is a more
niche topic in 2021 what's your
relationship with podcast both as
producing it but also
because you're so of the you know the
modern consumer culture
i'm curious what you're what you're
listening to and what you intake
okay i first of all i've been a podcast
fan for four years
and there's a part of me that feels like
um and i and
so by saying this i'm sure you've heard
it before but i grew up on watching
black and whites with my mom and every
time i remember watching old school
movies
they would be sitting by the radio and
listening
and there was theater remember when
radio was because there was no
i feel like it i feel like history is
just repeating itself
podcasts for me um especially during the
pandemic
were pivotal like in terms of that was
the way i kept in touch with the world
and i stayed sane
the future literally because i had to
listen to
so many different programs that that
gave me different perspectives that gave
me some entertainment
right because because social and media
and the mainstream media both social
media and mainstream media was so heavy
you're saying that you used podcasting
as a little
balance of escapism it was so
heavy and and quite frankly yes it was a
part of the heaviness because i would be
posting and talking about it
as you should we all what we all were by
the way so keep going
i had to but then i needed to take a
break and i needed to get my mind off of
it so
podcasting for me got me through the
pandemic the early early stages i
literally would clean the house um
turn up the as loud as possible and it
felt like i was actually interacting
with people and getting away the future
to me
um is so bright i think we've learned
now
as a result this is the way that we're
going to be able to do tv shows the way
that you and i are talking now
this is going to be the way in which we
are going to communicate to people in a
safe
but entertaining way that doesn't feel
intrusive
there's something about being able to
sit at home and listen to a podcast and
feel as if you're there and you're
having an experience
and i think honestly i don't know why we
didn't think about that before i don't
know about you gary i always have to be
on the go
go go go go go it is so hard for me to
leave the house because i am
lot man i don't want to leave the house
i have all i look at my fingertips
podcasting producing watching anything
music all of it it is
really truly going to be the biggest
medium if not it already is
i mean who i mean are you watching tv
anymore i like
streaming you know uh real real quick
cloud therucia i'm so sorry like i i do
interrupt a lot on normal podcasts and
when i have 10 minutes and i want 13
things
so i apologize i love i'm i feel like
i'm just talking to friends and i
apologize
to you and anybody else we're just
trying to get to a ton with carrie so
carrie
what about real quick just because i'm
going to nerd a little bit on the sports
front
who's going to win the nba championship
i just need your hot take
okay i can talk about this all day with
you um everyone wants to see brooklyn
and lakers right that's not gonna happen
no
it's not gonna happen so i'm just
preparing you now everyone be okay with
it it's not gonna happen there are a
couple of things and i'm a die-hard
laker fan i don't know if you know that
i don't think that a.d is going to be
100 i think we're saving lebron and a.d
until the very last minute
and i hope that works but i just don't
think he's going to be 100
because i do believe i'm concerned that
his injury is more than what we are
hearing
um i don't know that i just that's just
me my gut and then i also think on the
other end we're going to watch brooklyn
and while they're amazing i think
they're going to implode
i don't when's the last time you've ever
seen anything like that
this team is has so many superstars
and they are sell selfless not selfish
selfless
but i honestly believe
when it comes down to it they're going
to implode because
someone's going to want to have the ball
in their hands all the time and it's
going to really start to affect
because i and i'm going to say i'm going
to say this i love james harden i think
he's amazing
but when you go ring chasing it never
works in your favor
it just doesn't so if i if i had to
guess it's going to be a surprising team
for us it's going to be a team that we
haven't really been looking at
what's your intuition right now i know
it will change as you get better data
down the stretch
this is very far off nobody should be
able to nail
it i'm trying to make you i'm trying to
make you feel safe but i'm generally
yeah
is it that celtics milwaukee
i honestly believe i it could be
milwaukee
i think that they're going to be doing
something special i think the celtics
are
definitely in there but i'm right now
i'm going from the east and it's not
going to be brooklyn
and it might be so it literally will be
milwaukee if i'm pretty sure i think i
think our guy needs to
to feel as if he is tired of people
saying that he's not good and he needs
help and he hasn't arrived and he's
really gonna go hard in the paint i mean
he's just
and by the way not for nothing he's just
a free giannis is a freak no one is
saying anything about what a freak
athlete he is and he's been quietly
making
his case so i'm excited about it okay i
will say that i do think the world has
said
something about his freak athleticism
his literal name is the greek freak
yeah yeah as the greek freak his name
but he's been getting
so much bad press lately gary i agree
for no reason i think we nicknamed him
the greek freak and then we took it back
not me per se but you know i think we we
then dismiss him because he can't show
up in
in a way in which we have already
crowned him and i think he's taking that
personally you know what i'm saying
i okay so let me ask you who do you
think is gonna win
i think it's gonna be brooklyn and the
lakers in the nba finals uh everyone
thinks so
that's great honestly i i
just don't see the alternatives clearly
enough yet
but things but you know like we saw with
miami and the bubble
like i'm also a very big fan of momentum
at the moment
i think if you look at the history of
sports it really matters what's
happening as you go in
who would have thought miami would have
made it to the finals
nobody i didn't and and quite frankly i
knew that they were
not going to do well because they didn't
have enough nobody would have said they
would have made it to the finals i
we're going to be surprised i just and
it's just the nature of
these guys are tired they haven't had
any time off i feel like
that's a very big point because of the
limited nature of their break
of the off season that's something i
haven't thought about
really they're exhausted i would love to
say my lakers are going to do it and i
will say that you know as a fan but i'm
like i know you're tired they're
exhausted they didn't have any time off
and they were told they were going to
have time off
before they went back to start the
season they were told they were not
going to have an all-star
they would have a break during that time
they did not have a break they did an
all-star
the league has con has literally made
these
there's no more yeah kerry final
thoughts what about doing a podcast what
was the biggest challenge what's the
most
fun i forgot about that we're talking
podcasts um
basketball is fun right um the best part
of doing a podcast is that you get to
tell
really for me um really creative stories
and it stretches the skill set that i
don't think i've had as a traditional
sports anchor as an anchor where you
read a prompter and you have to
you know stick to script and when you're
hosting sometimes there's a script for
the podcast you're just you're really
truly flexing a muscle that forces you
to
ad-lib think differently go deeper um
all of the things that we necessarily
aren't required to do when we're on
autopilot in our regular work lives if
that makes sense to you
beautiful and first of all you're just
amazing let me just be effusive about
how amazing you are okay
you're so nice um one more minute one
more minute one more minute
any time on have you spent any time on
clubhouse
yes is amazing i don't know if i
up but here i okay so i feel like it's a
loud room right now that here's the old
lady of me coming out with a lot of
people who
don't know about like i've been in a lot
of the sports i've literally been in a
lot of sports rooms and thinking okay
this is this is absolutely the same
yeah yeah but honestly it probably it
it's like twitter have you
have you hosted a room i haven't i love
you
that that's what's happening right
you're going into rooms just like
anything like any twitter facebook
instagram
it's not curated you should curate one
and see what it feels like for you
okay i should and see would you love it
tell me you love it
i love i love yeah i love i really like
it
and i like the concept of it and i think
it's going to be on every platform and i
like the people behind clubhouse and i
think they're going to continue to
innovate
i like people interacting with each
other
that's it that's it this is a new way to
interact is it a way to date because i
need a boyfriend is that a way to date
you're about to get completely bombarded
as you head out
see you later bye thank you thank you
guys for having me
next up we have the wonderful jim malika
jim is the first ever global cmo in bose
history and a 25-year vet in marketing
media
and digital commerce prior to bose jim
held
senior executive roles for global
corporations such as
under armour viacom mtv networks the
walt disney company
ralph lauren and nissan welcome jim
hey gary hey andrea how are you good jim
i don't see you popping up just yet i
can hear you let's see
let's see should
do you guys see the same thing i'm just
eating blueberries and raspberries i
love hearing
you know maybe we'll just do it with no
visual since we're talking about audio
um but let's see um team let's give it
one more chance to see if we can get jim
on screen
oh yeah any help nope
do you see do you see yourself on screen
he's
i go ahead that's my camera's
his video feed has frozen but his audio
is still coming through
can we try to reset him real quick maybe
go with the next vest and get him back
on right after
sounds good love you jim let's see in a
second
next up we have oola oberman the global
head of music at tick tock
oola is responsible for negotiating
music rights for tick tock and also
driving the long-term strategy for music
on the platform
since oola joined tiktok the business
has grown at pace
globally he's announced a series of new
licensing deals and partnerships
and place music at the heart of its
future and strategy
welcome oola
how are you i'm great gary how are you
very well my friend thank you for so
much for being on
now pleasure i love uh love the
conversation so far very exciting stuff
you know let's just jump on that when
you hear the things that everyone was
saying
about you know if you're winning on tick
tock you're now
you know in the top 100 songs top 10
songs
is that just humbling is that like
fascinating
you know you've been in the game a long
time you know it's just so black and
white
and it's it's a very it's all of a
sudden overnight you're in this
incredible power position
which comes with big responsibility how
are you calibrating
the fact that you're getting these
probably silly questions from labels and
artists of like hey can you
make my song go viral like you know all
that silliness that comes along with the
with the responsibility yeah do
you know what we we talk about this all
the time the
i think the culture at tiktok and the
team
that we're putting together that works
on music
were were obsessed with music we're
really passionate about music
we love the labels we love the
publishers we love the artists we love
working with the industry
and and i want to talk about this a
little you know there's there's so many
sides to how tick tock is working with
those different parts of the industry
um and i think it can all co-exist in a
beautiful way like i
i pulled um a little little data sheet
here that i want to share with you
because i think it it
epitomizes what's happening on tick tock
in an incredible way i looked at
uh the top five songs
from a creation standpoint globally
for march right and and let me read you
these top five artists
gibeon elliado los disos del ritmo
xylo stef londo do you do you know any
of those
right no i well i'm like you know that's
in your world so yes but to your point
that's what's happening yeah right now
now look that
that's happening those are those are
literally tens of billions of creations
in a month for those songs or those
artists and what i hope happens to every
one of those
artists is you know they do the
distribution deal
they do the do the label deal they get a
publisher signing them
whatever works for them right what do
they do whatever works for them that's
not your role exactly
but but i think it is our role and our
responsibility
to make sure that these artists get all
the right tools and
almost like all the education to some
extent for how can they
kind of optimize their chance of success
right and again going back to what i was
saying in the beginning like
that is kind of the ethos of of my team
and all the music teams that we have
around the world at tik tok like we're
all
building these relationships with these
artists many many of whom we've never
heard of before
um and they're just breaking on tick
tock but then the other side to what
those five i just read for you you know
there are 20 50 100
major label signed artists who are
breaking a new song on tick tock right
now
and what we see happen is that song goes
viral on tick tock
and literally 24 48 hours later it's in
the spotify charts it's in the amazon
charts it's in the apple music charts
and that's beautiful right so so it's
it's the two sides of it
it's it's being this incredible
marketing and promotion machine
um and and you know globally just
amplifying music
that the fans want to hear um and then
it's
also giving these unsigned unknown
artists from every corner of the world
a chance to to find their audience and
and that's what i think
you know it's it's incredibly invigorate
i mean i've worked in music
and sometimes the reason that song went
to the moon was some teenager
or some 40 year old decided to dance to
it because they stumbled on it
they as a human in their house did
something creative that people liked
and that became the match that it you
know
what an incredible feeling for some
people around the world right now
who made the original piece of content
with an unknown artist song
that started they didn't have a big
audience but somebody that did
saw it they decided to do something and
they're literally
one of the reasons that this person's
career changed yeah yeah yeah
right so so what i was going to say
earlier kind of segues nicely into this
you know i worked 25 years in major
record labels
loved my time there learned a ton have
lots of great friends who i'm in touch
with every day and obviously now we can
talk about how do we
help their artists on tick tock um but i
also saw the reason i came to tik tok i
saw this thing
changing before my eyes and it's it's
the power of ugc it's the power of user
generated content
you know and it is the artist and the
fan basically having a real-time
conversation with one another
and then this incredible creativity
comes out of that because
think about the stories that get told on
tick tock in 15
30 60 seconds and how music plays a role
in telling those stories either it's the
primary story or maybe it's the
secondary story but it's the story right
and
and that's just exciting that's what
people connect to
that's what they get excited about um
you know and i think that's why we're
having all the success
um i i you know i've been listening all
along and like
after ryan's talk earlier i was thinking
to myself you know how cool is it going
to be he
he is going to continue to find artists
on tick tock
and he's going to end up writing or
producing a song with some artists again
we never heard of
before and that ours is going to go to
the top of the billboard chart you know
hopefully
months after the fact because that
connection
was made on tick tock because because we
were able to sort of
unearth that really talented musician my
friend you as a human
what is your consumption on audio you've
you've established your enthusiasm for
music as a person you said we all are
so i'm just going to make that
assumption take me into podcast land
and if you don't listen to a single
podcast that's awesome because i don't
for example but i'm just curious you as
a consumer
where do you sit on audio consumption
outside of music
if anywhere yeah i'm i'm mostly still
music
you know i i'm extremely passionate
about music and frankly to some extent
it's my job so i want to be on top of
all these trends i want to hear all this
music i love you know when the guys in
brazil tell me
about something or korea or japan and i
just want to be on top of that
but i have i think you know maybe
pandemic lockdown
time for self-reflection uh ted talks
um and and sort of some of these
educational
or you know kind of uh personal growth
type category i've been i've been
getting into that um and i'm really
enjoying it so i'd say probably
90 music and maybe 10 that in the last
handful months
for fun to make everybody smile because
it's what happens a lot of time when
progressive uh executives come to new
platforms
if you can shoot shoot it straight i'm
asking you for the real answer
the first time musically or tick-tock
hit your radar when you were
not in the ecosystem yeah did you
dismiss it did you think it was silly
did you or were you on it like give me
that journey
so so this is i love this question
because um
i like kind of thinking back to this
look i was in these label jobs
and one of the beautiful things about
being in in this as a global business
development
um person for warren i was the chief
executive officer warner um
i was meeting with every digital music
and music platform around the world
seeing if we wanted to do deals with
them
so i had an incredible perspective and
along comes
tick tock or it was doing at the time
because tick tock hadn't launched
and i remember i was living in london
where i still live
visiting new york in our new york office
completely jet-lagged
three about three to six a.m jet lagged
lying in bed scrolling through these
videos
almost all the songs were in mandarin or
chinese but the videos and the
the sounds that i was hearing i was
completely obsessed and the thing i
thought to myself i was like
i was like music marketing is never
going to be the same when you've got
a thing like this that is just you know
15 30 60 second clips
it's basically the hook just getting one
hook after the next being kind of sent
your way
and you have the power to scroll through
if you don't want to listen or you just
let it do its thing
you sit back passively and hopefully you
discover music it was
it was not a dismissal it was a whole
other way
my mind is blown and i love this thing
and then
you know things happened and here i am
so i'm very very fortunate
oh thank you for your time my friend
yeah great to see you take care
take care bye
so gary we're going to welcome back jim
malika the cmo of bose
fingers crossed all right
here we go see jim here we go jim i have
the great
knowledge of how handsome you are so i
have
no way was i willing to do this without
the world
seeing that put him that face yeah
killing me
killing me killing me you uh i i need
you to remind my wife for that occasion
thank you my friend thank you jim as i
set up the question
and you can take it anywhere jim the guy
jim the executive cmo
at pose when we talk about future music
audio
and sonic in a 2021 and beyond world
where do you what what are the first hot
takes
all right give me one chance though
first you had carry-on we're talking nba
you know no one loves the nba
more than i do i gotta tell you i gotta
tell you
clippers bucks clippers bucks that's the
way it's going
grind it grind deep teams teams with
their chips on their shoulder
this is the year so book it okay hot
takes
uh for the future of audio uh in 2021 i
don't know
look um being sort of uh an amateur
futurist on these things a couple things
that a couple things i think are
interesting to me
um i think this idea of podcasts and
carrie brought this up right of the old
uh storytelling around radio
that you know as you start to see these
things like 3d
audio where people now are starting to
think about
audio and formats and storytelling where
you're moving your head you're hearing
you know elements from different
directions almost like a st like the
difference between a movie and a stage
production
i think this can be some really
incredible stories around that i know
people are playing with those things
i don't think it's ready for prime time
but i think it's another
level of immersion and depth like the
thing that i really like about podcasts
is how intimate it is right so i think
that's interesting and the other one i
think is really interesting is
um what you keep out right it's the
noise that you keep
out of your life whether it's just
distraction
stress frustration hearing loss
i think there's something around this
like i don't know
soundscape that you're able to curate
that is really interesting to me to help
you for
you know whether it's meditation or or
sleep
you know you're fairly new into the role
of cmo at bose you're you're at under
armour prior to that
what was the the best pleasant surprise
you know you obviously boze you know
like you we all have like right you have
your kind of intuition your
curiosities probably some reservations
what was the
what was the most pleasant surprise when
you walked into the four walls
i could not believe the sense of passion
and teamwork there was
around the company i got a sense because
when i was going through the process
with with the other execs that i had met
but when you get down into the teams
there is such a commitment to
audio it's just like a singular focus on
creating the most you know premium audio
experience for people that just
love music um that was
just so real something like i don't know
more than half of the company
uh or musicians so that was the thing
that was just
shocking yeah i mean it's
look you you gravitate towards you know
you gravitate towards your passion and
if you can work against one of your
passions
um and help bring that you know passion
out for other people like these
you know there's just a real commitment
there which is amazing how's the team
or the company thinking about podcasting
if at all when i say that word
in a bose world is there anything unique
going on any
clever things going on well i think it's
i think it's too early to say
you know unique or clever i think you
know um
i think there's a huge opportunity in
podcast with with the growth of it
to get more you know not the live reads
or
just just being able to immerse yourself
in the topics
um and and really derive you know uh
authenticity around the content for a
company like bose to not be
deeply immersed in podcasts a total mess
because it's a different listening
experience it's interesting
you know when when you guys were just
talking now thinking about like
music versus versus podcasts like i'm a
huge music junkie right follow my whole
life on
you know what records i bought at what
time
but i'm super passionate about podcasts
too it's just a different listening
experience right like
you know sometimes you go out for a run
and you just you you don't want to hear
music right and sometimes you do
and i think there's a way that we can
immerse ourselves in there both from
the standpoint of you know helping um
helping people you know achieve their
passions and just attaching ourselves to
that kind of experience
and making it better the biggest biggest
issue i have a podcast is sort of
how how do you how do you actually you
know
feel that the uh investment spend
is is is super accountable right like
you know it's something just from a
return on objective
right like you know it's like yeah
there's some goodness there
but it's not like your match market
testing or you know
yeah i mean i think i think it all
depends on where you sit on
on sales versus branding right i mean
what's the return on objective when you
put your logo
on you know on a billboard or right on a
sports team jersey
you know i think that's more i'm like
what's the conviction of the marketer
inside right right but at some point
right at some point you start
questioning that like okay
um yeah we got to do both we got to
drive sales
always by the way two things
one everyone's commenting on the fact
that they think you have a great
podcasting voice
so a from the feedback of the consumer
you may want to consider to start one
because you're winning people over
um by the way quick shout out to
montestar
who says guys don't be fooled this is
not live eat that
eat that [ __ ] monta style um number two
everyone's asking what you're wearing
you know what what uh what are you
wearing
these are the uh bose quiet comfort uh
earbuds um
incredible to block out the noise and
incredible sounds so
on that note interesting question do you
think you have a chance
for explosion in business because i had
a very weird meeting yesterday
where we were talking about getting the
office backed up to speed
me saying that either that when meetings
are done it's either rooms or zooms
no mix that meetings where
half the room see where i'm going i will
not approve
meetings where eight people are there
and three are there because we're going
to be doing a bunch of stuff right
so i so i've coined it rooms or zooms
which then leads to a lot of people
doing meetings at their desk conference
meetings with nine people
all who might be in the office or might
not be and then marcus
marcus my chief of staff who's always
keeps me in check
you know people like do you have anybody
who challenges you i'm like [ __ ]
marcus doesn't let me get away with [ __ ]
you know um you know says yeah but you
know what even
even around your office gary people
don't want to work there
because because it's a little loud and
zack nadler from vaynerspeakers is
talking
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i was a little
concerned and think i'm like wait a
minute we need to hit up gym
and [ __ ] like yes canceling is going
to become [ __ ] huge
totally totally so so two quick things
on that number one i totally agree with
you
the worst meetings of the world where
you have part of the team on zoom
and part of the team uh live because
what happens is garbage
garbage the people the people are
completely disengaged
right and they're not brought into there
and so um yeah
yeah totally totally then you know
what's gonna happen you know what's
gonna happen
then we're not gonna take advantage of
what we learned in covid which is to
take advantage of these things
better work-life balance better reality
is better like i want to make it
awesomer
for my employees that means we have to
go rooms or zoom
no other way totally and if you look
also
embrace some of the elements i mean
there's been a lot of [ __ ] with covert
and you know
it goes without saying there's been some
hard times about not being able to get
together with people and i think that's
one of the reasons why
i've gone so deep on podcasts is because
it feels like i'm talking guys at the
bar
right whether it's business or whether
it's sports or whether it's music so
that's helped me
but one of the great things about
podcasts right now i'm looking over your
head like oh it's cool piece of art
that's really interesting you get to
know a little bit about somebody kid
runs into a frame
the dog runs into a frame there's some
humanity there which is kind of nice
right you see a different dimension of
people
these things around noise canceling i
think that there's an element of it just
allows you to lock and load right
and if you can lock and load and focus
for brief periods of time
that it's really really impactful and
then disengage for a bit and refresh
yourself so yeah totally i'll set you up
no worries
love it love you jim andrew let's keep
this moving we'll talk to you soon thank
you
okay take care we'll see you later
thanks jim next up we have microsoft's
amy cirocus
amy is the director of strategic
partners partnerships at microsoft where
she connects
artists to fans serving up creative tech
tools that help the world make listen
and experience
music amy has also helped showcase
social causes of artists giving them a
broader platform
to spark change and do good amy's advice
to anyone
starting their career is don't
compromise on your perspective
just because it's different than your
co-workers welcome amy
thank you nice to see you here it's so
good to have you
i i love that last statement i am a
buyer buyer buyer buyer buyer
of that statement amy let's get right
into it because we've been running out
of time with everybody because he's 10
minute blasts i want to get as much in
um when when i pose this question to you
what is the future of music
audio and or sonic branding in a 2021
world how do you and microsoft
see that what or you even amy
the as the human not the executive how
do you how do you
take that in what is this um what is
what is this
land in your mind and how yeah i think
the interesting things
that um are exciting at microsoft and
for me
are really thinking about what you guys
have been talking about a little bit
about
the connection between the fans and and
the
music artists and how the different
kinds of experiences we're having
virtual mixed with physical now is going
to get interesting and
how people are thinking about expanding
that connection point
beyond when they can physically be
together at a show and
obviously we've been exploring that
space a lot in the last year
but in the total digital realm
so now as we start to blend i think it's
going to get really
exciting so that's that's what i'm
really pumped about for
the next year and beyond what what what
do you think is going on
have you actually because we haven't
touched on a lot of people i keep seeing
them ask it
sonic branding the notion of a sound you
know xbox
obviously does that extremely well is it
something on your on your mind
is it something you think about or is
that still a little bit off to the side
while there's other things to be
thinking about is that's an emerging
thing
now we definitely think about it a lot
at microsoft we've
we've had a history of of really being
considerate about our sonic branding and
that continues when we think about the
brand we think about
the voice uh the look and the sound
so i think that the you know the team
continues to dig into that
and really consider how it comes to life
across
our products our marketing how we show
up
in the world in different ways so um
it's exciting to
be a piece of a piece of the puzzle in
that
um and and think about that for a big
brand like microsoft with a lot of
different products so we do try to think
about the connectedness there too
and sounds so important people people
know what it is
when they hear a noise in the distance
right so
it's powerful in your role
in the filter of this question what is
top agenda right now um
i would say in my role it's really
thinking about how we can
use technology in really innovative ways
with
artists so i try to do a lot of direct
work with
with different artists and use our
products and services
and different microsoft technologies the
whole toolbox that we have
in in different in unique ways sometimes
pushing the product that was originally
built for
retail or banking or whatever it is and
taking it into a very creative space and
and trying to figure out how it can be
used as a tool
for artists explorations and their
expression
and that's that's a lot of fun we get to
push things around a little bit in ways
that
maybe weren't supposed to originally but
really
helping them helping the artists that we
work with
bring their vision to life bring that
crazy
or you know innovative wild idea in
their mind
um to life and into something that their
fans can
experience or they can put out in the
world and
be be doing something very unique
hopefully amy i also find that microsoft
has a really long
like history with you know with music
right is that outside your house it's my
house okay good
are they tearing are you are they
tearing down a tree or like the
neighbors
renovating things it's seattle they're
building things everywhere
i literally went on pause i'm like
what's new york city doing now okay no
problem at all i just wanted to triple
check amy sorry
no worries at all an incredible history
of like
music in a lot of ways too what about
you know
so obviously on the artist front trying
to do different
partnerships and collaborations um what
about on the podcast side
like you know i don't feel like i have a
great feel and i'm kind of
in the trenches i don't have a great
feel of the state of the union of
microsoft and podcasting what's going on
in your world on that front if anything
yeah i think um so from for me i think
it's an interesting area to explore
kind of the things you were you're just
talking about in
in terms of you know 3d uh audio
and sonic experiences that can stretch
um into the podcast world that bring to
life
ways for people to interact or
experience sound
in really really different compelling
ways
um so we've been you know windows
windows has a sonic engine
as part of the services and we've been
experimenting with that with different
artists we've we did a project with x
ambassadors actually that was
a music video without video
so we really relied heavily on the idea
of how
a spatialized audio could play into that
kind of experience and paint a picture
um without a picture and so
we're really you know digging into that
a bit and thinking about how that
can play through into music experiences
that also then would stretch into sort
of the podcasting world and
and what could happen uh there i think
there's also really interesting bridges
between
what people are starting to experiment
with with with
podca audio podcasts having some kind of
visual
components and ways to experience them
in different ways that obviously then
needs a you know a computer or
an uh mixed reality device or something
like that so we're starting to
you know kind of talk about storytelling
in those ways which i think
opens up lots of opportunities for the
podcasting world
and finally what about amy s the actual
human being
the non-executive where where do you sit
on podcasts
and music what are what are some of the
things you're listening to
and or some of your favorite all-time
artists in music
oh oh big questions there yes i'm
dropping the bomb at the end here
podcasts that i've been enjoying i
really have enjoyed michelle obama's
podcast i love the humanity in that and
learning about her and her friends and
just opening up in that way that's
so so great um i'd say uh
you know unfortunately i probably am in
the same boat of everybody else i don't
have tons of time
to consume lots of podcasts um but music
i keep the music on
all the time uh all-time favorite band
is the pixies hands down
my favorite current um artists
are um uh fontaine's dc heard about them
uh out of out of ireland uh good
rock kind of old band the rock alt scene
in general
has a lot more momentum going on
recently
yeah yeah in my
suits saying a few years ago now um
it's probably been a few uh at uh south
by southwest there were a lot of bands
wielding their guitars again and it's
happening it's coming through now so i
i i miss getting together with people
and seeing
kind of what's up and coming in those
kinds of
um environments and other you know
conferences and festivals and things
because
you kind of can see where where the
directionally different paths of the
music genres are
are going because there's no genres
anymore they're all a big blend
are you uh are you jonesing to just get
back to the real world quote unquote
absolutely i can't wait for new mo's to
reopen in seattle i
think that we're all missing the the
small
the small venues and the big festivals
so can't wait
for it amy thank you for your time yeah
thank you
excited to bring up our next speaker
troy carter
troy is the founder and ceo of q a a
tech and media company focused on
powering the business of music
via distribution services and data
analytics
before q a troy was the founder and ceo
of adam factory
where he nurtured the careers of global
superstars including
lady gaga and john legend welcome troy
thanks for having me gary what's good
bro it's good to see you
it's good same here i'm really really
happy to see you i'm
very excited to pose this question um
you've had a long career at being at the
forefront of many of these things
what's your current take on where
music is in 2021 and then i'll ask you a
little bit about
uh podcasting and sonic branding
yeah i i think we're seeing um
a real mindset shift into into
independence
you know i think that sort of that
mindset had been bubbling but
now i think we're seeing a significant
amount of outside capital
coming to the music industry but also
you're seeing
other tools that that are starting to
pop up so
um so i'm i'm really bullish about the
the independent
music space and then also just looking
at
you know just the opportunities that
blockchain is
is going to provide um i i really feel
like we're getting ready to hit this
tipping point that's going to shift from
sort of major label control to complete
artist control
and the way that we saw the nba take
that shift from sort of being
um ownership control to to player-led
i think we're going to see something
very similar in music
do you think that one day the players
will have so much leverage in the nba
that they'll start their own league
absolutely it's i think it's just a
matter of time i think i think that
you know you know how big of a statement
that is though right troy
because i think everybody who's
listening right now can wrap their head
around
oh with nfts and blockchain they're
going to
you know these artists are going to not
sign these bigger deals and it's going
to be managers or
infrastructure or labels that adjust
that will be partners in crime but the
economics will be different
you know i've been honest
i want to see those five guys play those
five
guys no matter what so you're you're
listen by the way the reason i jumped in
on this and this may take up the entire
talk
is i've been saying this for about two
years
i i've got videos on it i get crazy
emails like you're an idiot
and i'm like you don't understand what i
think i'm seeing which is
you said it leverage tilts really the
only leverage at this point
that the ownership has is the places
these games are played in
because they own a good majority of the
venues which i do not think is a big
enough deal oh by the way
because i'll go watch the five and five
in seton hall's gym
or the garden i'll watch it outside in
the park and probably enjoy it more
comma it's get like
forget about them take tomorrow if the
top
15 nba players have this conversation
go find 15 billionaires if lebron's like
yo oprah
let's talk about this and go in 50 50
where the billionaire puts up the money
all of a sudden the world basketball
federation
feels very real to me in a way that i
don't think people see it
i do think people see it a little bit
more with music but i think
a hundred percent it's going to happen
with the nba over the next half century
for sure which is a long period of time
there's
but i think it's going to happen is in
it and it's actually
a bit easier to do it um in the nba than
the music correct
correct go ahead
reason being is distribution
for those 15 guys that you that you're
talking about
is is pretty easy because you know
whether you're a network streaming
service whatever you know people are
going to show up to to watch them play
and in music the issue is it's not
15 people it's you know 70 000 songs
a day that has to make their way through
so when you
when you're sort of fighting for well
the same now look there's 70
000 people that are playing i play
basketball every day too there's you
know
to you know to the same point there's
the superstars
if if literally player number 49 the
49th best
and most popular basketball player hit
up the next 20 guys underneath him and
said let's start a league
they'd be dead absolutely we need one
through 15. that's where the tipping
point is
absolutely what when did blockchain
and music opportunity friction
you know innovation really click in your
head
in this last forget about knowing about
bitcoin ethereum and all things but like
has it been in the last year last six
months last four months where you're
like
like because we all have these moments
right i remember this late december i'm
like
oh for like my nft thesis did
in the last six months which is i'm
gonna make a year i don't wanna
i don't wanna lead i wanna know where
you it was for you when were you like
oh so so i met with
the founders of audience probably two
two and a half years ago
and they they were talking about you
know this this idea of
a streaming service built on blockchain
and you know what what they were talking
about is sort of how can we go after the
music industry
the music industry has the most
complicated right structure
that you want you see that's absurd so i
by the way it's one of the reasons i
never professionally got into music
i'm like [ __ ] that [ __ ] it is it is
absurd
and and it scares people off and and a
lot of it is
purposely opaque and designed in a way
where you can keep the system the way
the system is designed
but when you really you know peel back
the layers on this
it should be a much simpler it should be
much simpler if if gary if you and i
make a song together um and we want to
release it
it shouldn't be really complications
around ownership we did it together
right
and and so when you look at you know how
blockchain works
it was built for for these particular
situations
and when you look at being able to track
and
like royalties things along those lines
um
direct relationships with fans is really
built for it but when audience talked
about it
i just knew it wasn't ready for major
labels and they wouldn't go anywhere
near it
but where they were smart they went
after electronic music and dance music
where you know where it was lower
hanging fruit and now
i think that the the the i think artists
have caught on through nfts
and and kind of seeing what's happening
in that space
and and explaining it to them is much
simpler now
they actually see it in action so i
really i feel like the next three years
is it's gonna we're really gonna see
this accelerate
i agree there's a lot and the record
labels
like the biggest thing that the record
labels have always had is a is
a big checkbook and sort of distribution
and and when artists don't necess when
they feel like hold on i can make money
off of this i can get cash flow off of
this i can own my own audience i got
district
what do i need period
troy what about podcasting for you are
you a consumer
have you have you know what do you when
you think about podcasting how does that
play in your head
um i still think we're early you know um
i was a i was an early investor in
gimlet
um that that sold the spotify so i
invested in them probably five years ago
and um and as a space that i personally
love as a consumer
but it's the worst consumer experience
i've ever seen
in terms of you know um curation so
where
at spotify they did an amazing job in
terms of being
able to figure out playlist and
discovery
and um and i i feel like in podcasts and
they
no one's gotten there yet so i'm looking
forward to a better
consumer experience in this space but
nothing i love
you're you're looking for from a
standpoint of curation
yeah and not so so basically
the the way it works right now is that
where if
in music if i they've done a really good
job in music in terms of
figuring out if i like a certain type of
artist i like a certain type of genre i
like a certain type of song um they made
it easier for me to go through playlists
and things like that to discover things
in a
very very easy way and podcasting
it might only be one episode that that
that i
like of a podcast you know and so
so just really being able to to match a
little better and
and make the flow a little better is the
the discovery is just not there for me
yet
two rapid fires around audio
the alexa or the google home in the
house
are you do you use and is it still just
a play this song
and a novelty item or to use it
functionally and then
two clubhouse twitter spaces have you
played
hot takes on both before i let you out
of here big big big fan
of of clubhouse and with them what they
built and i
you know i've been on it since um early
part of last year and just
fell in love with the voyeurism of being
in the
bounce room in the room and i think it's
going to be hard for other people to
compete with what clubhouse is
is built um i saw i like it a lot
um and in terms of uh
alexa alex i don't use either by the way
no listening devices in my house because
you don't want them listening
i don't want them listening and you
believe that absolutely
that is an incredible way to end troy i
love you bro have a good day
next up we've got noel chestnut whitmore
noelle has nearly two decades of
experience in the music industry
working for some great brands in music
fashion and entertainment including katy
perry
rolex chanel coachella jay-z and kanye's
watched the throne tour and more during
the pandemic noel produced
and directed lion king the musical on
clubhouse
this went viral and led her to becoming
the cmo of the geo jam but let's let her
tell the story
welcome noelle thank you such a pleasure
to be here i'm so grateful to be here hi
gary
hey noel how are you i'm doing great how
are you
good i think a lot of people don't know
that story so i think a lot more should
so i'm going to let you tell that story
like andrea set us up take it away sure
so
i'm a 32 year old cmo former artist
multi-instrumentalist
multi-hyphenated creative um turn tech
cmo
um i had gotten furloughed from
golden voice had been working in the
live experiential space for the past 12
years
and then um got furloughed due to the
pandemic
and then stumbled on this platform
um this new platform emerging platform
called clubhouse where
i had um looked into building
additional activations i have an
organization called more music where i
host panel discussions and
found this amazing user community um
this people who i've been able to
connect with in an amazing way
and then um through the serendipity of
connecting and
connecting with amazing people on the
platform um and hearing an amazing voice
by the name
of this gentleman named chris boogie who
literally sounds just like james earl
jones
the idea of doing um
the lion king came to mind and in the
spirit of bringing joy the day after
christmas
and literally had no idea what was going
to be the outcome on the other side
and we trended number two nationwide um
under the nfl um break and breaking a
bunch of records broke the app
two times we did two performances of it
and then
it literally created this new landscape
of how people
engage and utilize the audio space on
that platform
um because we had created a specific use
case
that was unique in the sense of we use
audio
live instrumentation imagery interaction
engagement and what i'm calling
interactive podcasting which is this
sense of ways that people can interact
and engage
um and use their imagination to build
this reality that they see for
themselves as well as ways for consumers
to engage in new ways
and then sorry please please that is
where and then
through that um i was connected to sarah
who is the amazing ceo of geojam who is
a big fan of yours by the way
and um she she um
reached out to me on linkedin so that i
was furloughed and here i am
now the cmo of gojam is super excited
and so grateful to be here
i mean how often do you think about my
god this
very challenging global pandemic that
had
all these difficult things literally the
circumstances of that completely
completely changed the course of your
life you know how do you think about
serendipity and and kind of being
optimistic
and kind of moving forward versus
today since you were just so impacted by
it
versus who you are as a young lady prior
to that
does your perspective change on oh
this is what happens when [ __ ] like this
goes down yeah
it's like it's one of those things like
i have been asked this question because
obviously my life has changed
significantly it's one of the beautiful
things that
when i took the moment to have the pause
the much necessary pause that was needed
in my life to reflect and think about
how do i want to be intentional about
how i move in the space what are my core
values what do i care about
who are the people that i care about and
as a person who is very
moved by service of other people it was
one of those things where
as this pandemic hit me it was i knew
how to pivot
and to shift into the things that
allowed me to bring joy to not only
myself and
spark this new creativity but also be in
service of things
that allow which is what i'm super
excited about with geo jam
allow their favorite artists and fans to
connect in ways that have
never been done before um when i started
in the live space
it was the joy that brought me and when
i did my first concert at 19 it was
being able to create this level of
escapism
and being able to connect them with
their favorite artists and completely re
remove any stress any financial stuff
that you may have been going through
anything that you have been dealing in
the work environment and creating like i
said this escape
and this experience that would
ultimately allow
for um joy
and just happiness and thankfulness so
that is literally what i've been doing
my entire life but i appreciated it at a
whole nother level now
because it affected me in a specific way
that i had never affected me before but
it affected the world globally in a way
where we had to make
very intentional change as a community
to
how are we working and collaborating
with one another and how are we engaging
and connecting on content
music audio and in a way that is safe
but also in a way that allows us to
still have fun
which i'm all for having fun um
how does audio hit different than the
written word
or video in your opinion in my personal
opinion
audio allows for a
unfiltered interpretation and expression
of self
right you have these when you're dealing
with some of these other platforms you
have
to think about your appearance and how
you physically show up
you have to think about how the audience
is receiving the content right which
there's still some level of consumption
and thinking about the consumer
however you are for my case and
specifically for my story
it's like i am literally my authentic
vulnerable self this is what you get
and this and if you like it great but
the beautiful thing about audio is
there's a bunch of communities and niche
that you can find whatever you're
looking for and i think
the beauty of what is happening right
now not only within the audio space but
within music as a whole
is that people are looking for more more
reasons and ways in which they can
authentically
vulnerably you do you i'm sorry to
interrupt yeah yeah
you believe that the video support to
the audio
is leading people in such an aggressive
way that
just the audio has on the consumer side
allows for them to have a more
imaginative and potentially open
portal to the consumption of the
information
for sure and i think it sparks a
childlike imagination that i think we
all like
i think the beautiful thing with what
happened with lion king
is obviously that is such a classic
that's an iconic movie
and through the though we had the visual
representation and we
had utilized the ptr the changing of the
imagery
to as an uh as a narrative
for people to be able to have some sort
of visual reference
you had to use your imagination as a
form
of building this narrative in your head
while we were also
painting this picture utilizing audio
what about your own podcast
or alexa skills or your current
clubhouse
navigation you the human being not the
executive
what's your consumption these days um i
am
a content creator not only on that
platform but also on the platform which
i work for which is
a geo jam i think the beautiful thing
that i see about music and whether it's
audio
in the podcast form or music in
from like a consumption of like songs
from your favorite artists or in an
independent artist
i think the beauty of this platform and
all these platforms is it allows for
communities to be built
it allows for sharing of
music that you may be familiar with and
music that you may not be familiar with
as well as discovery
and then more importantly what i think
is super exciting about what we're doing
at geojam is we're allowing for fans and
artists to be connected directly
we're putting a fan on a private jet
this wednesday with 24k
golden and they're going to safely
they're going to be able to safely
interact and engage with an artist in a
way that they've never been able to do
before that's usually something that
would cost an amazing amount of money
where through the partnership that we
have with him his team
and through the through line that is
music which is how fans are able to
build this level of engagement and
excitement about this artist
we're creating an intimate interaction
that they are not able to get anywhere
else
i love it you were fantastic thank you
so much awesome thank you thank you talk
to you soon
bye
so excited to welcome our last speaker
corey martisoto
cmo of elf cosmetics we had to bring
corey back to talk about the
elfing amazing thing she's doing in the
music space
elf cosmetics has caught the attention
of millions through catchy music tunes
artist partnerships events and platforms
like tick tock and triller
cory continues to show the world that
anything is elfing possible
welcome back corey corey did you make
andrea write that last slide
i have to tell you though andrea has
been using elfisms on her own
since the last time i was here she
actually said her own elfism so
andrew by the way your photos behind you
are [ __ ] amazing
they're yeah they are pretty clear i'm
actually i was uh pushed down into the
basement
i'm in my husband's band room and he
happens to have all these rock stars so
i thought
all right it's not so bad today right
that makes sense
um take it away great to see you
too happy to be here thank you um so
let's just get right into the elfing
posit
possible of you know how has this
incredibly progressive marketing
engine behind this brand leveraged
audio um and music yeah
i would say the first thing is audio is
fundamental
and i think on the road ahead what
you're going to see with audio
is that it's going to be woven into the
fabric of brand building
it has to be right and the way that this
really happened at elf and how we
shifted it into the mindset into the
fabric
is we caught lightning in a bottle with
our hashtag
islipsfacechallenge on tiktok and
overnight we moved from being a beauty
company to a global music sensation
and what i wanted to do is say hold on a
minute
let's not review mirror that post
mortimer
ticket as a success and move on let's
translate this into more successes and
find
more ways to continue to make that magic
happen where we can be
at this incredible intersection between
the power
of music and the power of
self-expression which is
what we do through the beauty products
we create so
since that moment on tick-tock when we
really challenged ourselves to plunge
further into the music space
you know we weren't hanging out with
incredible people at republic records we
were interlaced with umg
we found ourselves in a new community
and
we decided to plunge into triller
and become the first beauty brand to do
a campaign there and
we know what everybody's doing on
trailer this is really a music platform
that has democratized the art of music
video creation so we said well how do we
play in this space
and we decided to drop a holiday album
so here we are
a beauty company dropping a holiday
album with emerging artists and the next
thing you know
we look at the billboard trailer charts
and it's mariah carey
jlo megan the stallion and elf cosmetics
so it was just this incredible moment
where we said okay we caught lightning
in a bottle again there's really magic
happening here at the intersection
of imagination self-expression wait to
experience that do you feel that you and
the team are
are just really over executing on the
attention and culture graph
i think so because when i look at the
macro i know there's a little side
question but i'm like
a little bit curious my own damn self
like you know like it's so obvious what
you're doing since i've lived that life
for the last 15 years like
you know this is obviously one component
of that but would you say if we're
leveling it up because we have a lot of
marketers watching
at a higher level whether it's music
whether it's tick tock whether it's
dancing whether
it's video whether it's gaming your
your north star right now is where is
the underpriced culture
and and attention and can we
authentically go in there
and and navigate and and and be creative
and contextual to that environment
correct hundred thousand percent
and incredibly well said the starting
point though
on that journey is really important
because everything's a starting block
the starting block is as individual
employees think beyond your role
you also have to think beyond your brand
and what i would add to that is think
beyond your industry
so as you know we love elephant alphysms
i love to say elf the rules
where does the magic happen the magic
happens when you corey i like to say
[ __ ]
i like to say [ __ ] the rules i don't
know if you know right now you're gonna
say off the rules
um no i'm gonna say [ __ ] the rules but
but i'm gonna support and cheater for
your version
of elf the rules go ahead so that that
magic is when you paint outside the line
so i would say that's the starting block
is just
get rid of the borders and the
boundaries the second part
is this mindset around you're not here
to sell product
you get that out of your head right what
is it that we're trying to do
create an orbit that people want to be a
part of
so what i like to say is that elf is an
entertainment company
that also makes makeup and skincare and
when you have 10 million people showing
up on your doorstep
every day or coming to your platforms
you have to be dynamic
you have to be multifaceted you have to
create something people not only want to
come to the first time but want to come
back to time and time again
and i would say the third part right so
now that you you're at these magical
intersections you've created this orbit
that people want to be a part of the
third part is to really think about your
marketing lovers as seduction
so i like to say marketing is the
seduction part commerce is the sex well
guess what you can't get to sex
without seduction first so if you think
about it like dating
you're not going to get very far if you
take somebody to the movies every single
night
right no one night it's the movies one
night it's a restaurant one night it's a
concert
it's the ability to seduce multiple
senses
and for me audio has to play a critical
part of that right it's sight it's touch
it's sound well will nfts be taking
someone to the museum for a little
culture
i think nfts i actually listened to your
clubhouse last night on nfts
i think it's a super fascinating space
that is
really going to be here for a long time
and a lot of brands like like tick tock
right people were afraid of it what do i
do with it how do i plunge in
i think a year from now nobody's asking
that question anymore they're
they're playing core um what uh
let's go into you the the person um
what is your podcast music uh
audio experience we can even add
clubhouse and even alexa
and google home if there's anything
there give us the breakdown
of the state of the union of how you
roll as the human not the elf executive
yeah so the way i roll is first thing i
do when i wake up
is i listen to podcasts when i get ready
in the morning really
i do it's i love podcasts i i just you
know heard i think it was two people
before this one
not loving the discovery experience i
totally agree i think the search engine
and the discovery on podcasts is just i
don't know
what what are you doing spotify or apple
or something else uh i do apple
and i do spotify i would i do both but i
have my
my trifecta in the morning which is the
daily
and then i go into what a day because i
feel like that's the news with a shot at
tequila and i need that because after
the day i need a shot to kill
uh and then i you know if i have enough
time npr and then obviously uh kara
swisher and scott galloway i'm
completely obsessed i know you had cara
this morning
so i take that in the two days a week
that they're so that's
how i get ready i'm doing my makeup i'm
listening to these podcasts so i've
already got
all that in my head and then i go about
my day and then the other ways in which
i'm playing with voice i mean i've got
spotify music on
all day uh so that's in the background
and i'm changing that according to what
meeting am i going into i
feel like now that i'm working from home
i change it according to my moods are
you
are you consuming more or less for the
same podcast with covet
more more more and then later on
clubhouse
i didn't trade anything off to get there
so this
is another more this is an incremental
what lost
during covid from you probably time with
my husband
[Laughter]
great answer i love the authenticity
that was helping funny
yeah i mean you know i i find clubhouse
to be
a fascinating experience because it's as
if i was listening to
pivot with scott and cara and now i can
actually jump in
and ask a question and engage with them
live and that's something that obviously
didn't exist i think clubhouse is a
great job finding the white space
what'll be interesting
from here is now that everybody else is
going to put that
feature technology on that their
platforms who's going where
and what is that look like i think you
know i think we just went through it
with snapchat
snapchat found the white space yeah
everybody created the
feature and clubhouse excuse me snapchat
innovated
and still was the core place along with
instagram
stories for that it'll be interesting to
see what happens with clubhouse it's
going to be on clubhouse to need to
innovate
you know i don't think instagram's
multiple people thing is
video thing is right i do think spaces
for twitter is
i do think facebook inc follows it
literally and we'll
find out corey it's really great to see
you again i love what is that officially
called that's a scarf
that's actually a scarf yes okay i like
your scarf
thank you great to see you gary thank
you
thanks gary and thanks everybody for
joining us did you know gary we're
taking
marketing for the now on the road to
australia next
i did not tell me so on april 28th
we're going to be interviewing six
leaders
six business leaders from 7 30 to 8 30
pm
eastern on april 28th interestingly it's
april 29th
in australia that's how it works i guess
they're always they're always a day
ahead
so uh really am i am i doing that you
are doing that gary
i'm doing that with amy bradshaw
yes you are and then we've got our one
year anniversary episode on may
6th from 12 to 2 p.m eastern and that's
a surprise episode so we'll be
sharing a little bit more about that
later andrea is the australia episode an
australian market-centric
right now absolutely and i'm and i'm
doing that you are with amy brad
with amy bradshaw you'll be ready i'm
wonderful in that market all right
everybody thank you so much for tuning
in a lot of good stuff today i hope you
took away some
good good good stuff please check out uh
uh
marketingforthenowmftn
to vaynerx.com up and register make sure
you miss none of these because i guess
we're going global now
um and we had some real great guests
andrea union team congratulations on
that
i hope everybody enjoyed it and we will
see you soon you can catch me on twitter
garyvee
i'll be going there shortly see ya thank
you everyone see you soon